the power women are here how are you
guys feeling the culmination of the
Skywalker's I know it's pretty exciting
and great to be here with everybody
celebrating and knowing that this is the
first audience that will see the movie
really exciting I'm very excited to be a
part of that
Palpatine coming back how long has this
been in the works that is a secret we
can talk a lot more about that after
this movie but I will say that when JJ
joined us and came back to this which
was an amazing thing for him to bring
this home it was exciting to be able to
pick up some of the ideas that were born
in the early days of developing the
force awakens and you know there there
may be some threads that were sort of
seeds that we're always there that feel
quite inevitable in this movie I gotta
ask which was harder kicking off this
leg of the trilogy or kicking off this
trilogy or wrapping it up I would say
ending it's been really really tricky
that's probably the hardest thing is the
hardest thing with anything because you
know we can have endless conversations
about where we're going but to really
find a satisfying conclusion has been
something I think is attached to all of
us well I got to say someone that's
taking the world by storm
baby Yoda you know we we certainly kept
baby Yoda secret because we didn't want
anybody to know what we were doing but I
have to admit Jon may disagree but I
really feel that this went way beyond
anything we anticipated it's not a
control like somebody nobody's just so
sweet and cute yeah so see everybody
wants to protect him your heart just
explodes you thought the screen so many
cute Forks baby Yoda I can't breathe
anymore
so this is the the combination of the
Skywalker saga we've heard talks of
there being breaks and the movies well
what's next well we had always decided
that we're taking a bit of a break after
finishing the saga and now we're really
starting to put pen to paper and figure
out where we're headed beyond this I
think Mandalorian is certainly an
indication of some of the ideas that are
percolating so we'll see and then we
have obi-wan oh yeah obi-wan is being
directed by Deborah Chao we're doing a
six-part limited series we were just
actually down in Manhattan Beach
yesterday looking at some of the cast
and that's really coming along so we're
excited I don't know if I'm allowed to
pick favorites but Deborah Chows episode
of the Mandalorian wasn't it great no
she is really talented amazingly
talented see this movie tonight
[Music]